The presence of God has been widely discussed for centuries
But no matter what you feel or think it is right
Can we use mathematics, universal language and unbiased
Let us come to a conclusion?
Can mathematics prove the existence of God?
The most famous argument is the use of logic for the benefit of the universe that exists by God
Is "the argument based on design"
Simply put, given how amazing and wonderful it is
Everything around us
Can we really believe it
That pure coincidence is the one who did it?
Even from the perspective of the world
Life is wonderful
Incredibly rare
It took a tremendous number of steps,
Seashells, time until all this is done
Therefore, a religious person can discuss
Does not that seem more reasonable?
There is a force behind all this
This type of argument is called:
Proof of the Back
Which he simply tries
Refute the argument by showing it
It inevitably leads to something ridiculous
Or impractical conclusions
In this case
It suggests: 1. If God does not exist, the evolution of mankind is unlikely
2. Human evolved
3. It is therefore unlikely that there is no God
But let us look further at this logic
And imagine the universe before there is anything
Here, we have a basic fund
Where we have two possibilities
The presence of God, or lack thereof
On the other hand we have these possibilities
The presence or absence of human beings
If the absence of a god is the truth
Thus human existence depends on several factors
So we will consider it a small possibility
We say that there are a quarter billion billion opportunities
For the existence of mankind
In a world without a god
If God is real
Although we do not know if God will create humans
But certainly he can
So we will give this greater probability
Of a quarter million
Certainly if we test the evidence
We can make sure we are there
So we can get rid of the other line
As many of you who have used the "design argument"
In which he was human and made by God
Seems more likely to be rational and statistical
Although this is true in many ways
They forget an important point
It is our assumption that there are only two main theories
But we know that this is not true
Several communities believed in multiple gods
Given that many aspects of life
Not beautifully complicated
Or intentionally intended
Perhaps differences between the gods
Find the universe
The mathematician uses Gordon Elnberg
The probability is 1 / 400,000
That Kona with several gods can lead to the creation of humans
But it is important to remember
The exact numbers do not really matter
What matters is that we can agree
Logically, Kuna has several gods
There is a greater possibility of human existence
From being a single God
Or no god at all
It is also important to remember
We do not compare prospects
The presence or absence of a god
We ask ourselves
If the Deity option is true
What is the probability of finding it for humans?
Then we ask separately
If the Gods option kit is correct
What is the probability of finding them for humans?
Now, let's take a look further
For theories we suggest that we live in simulation
As in "Sim"
Which is believed by people like Elon Mask
And Professor of Oxford Nick Bostrom
With the advancement of technology
The fact that humans in the future
They will create a real simulation of humans
Based on the world in which we live
To study these humans as we study mice
Scientists have used simulations
To understand nature and human behavior
But it is possible in the future
That humans as subjects of experience
They will be aware and believe they are real
So we can give this scenario
High probability
Again, the exact figures do not really matter
We agree that it is likely
Creating such a simulation by humans in the future
Compared to the possibility of the decision of God or gods
To find humans randomly
While they do not need this
Or while they can find millions of other animals
Or other areas of the universe
In the end, humanity is obsessed with human beings
So as you can see
While mathematics can really show us
That existence of life is evidence of the existence of God
Compare after its existence
The same mathematics can show us
A guide coming from several sources that we are the product of a more sophisticated human simulation
Special thanks to audible for supporting this episode to give you a free 30 day trial on audible.com/asap
This week we would like to suggest a book
'How Not To Be Wrong: The Power of Mathematical Thinking' by Jordan Ellenberg
Which was the main source of this episode
The wonderful book about hidden beauty and the logic of the world
Mathematical lenses
In an easy way for everyone
You can get a free 30-day trial on audible.com/asap
The choice is among a large group
We love them because they are wonderful in the way
And subscribe to more weekly science videos